This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey, this is Chris Abraham and
just a few hours ago I did
episode 33.
But I was thinking I was sitting
in Adido's cafe and this lovely
barista who I spent 45 minutes
with yesterday, stopped by and I
told her how.
Like spending 45 minutes talking
to her made my day and she like
came in and gave me a hug.
I mean she was standing, I was
sitting.
It was very nice gesture.
And she's a raised, she's a
could be a senior next year in
high school.
So she's a wee youngin.
And she was bragging yesterday
about her for a P for
psychology.
And I asked her, she's she's
she's mixed race.
She's half Costa Rican and half
Howley and beautiful smart girl.
Told me all about her anxiety
and her depression and she's the
most sweet and kind person.
And I was hoping it wasn't a
facade.
And it's not.
She's lovely.
I refuse to call lovely people
naive.
I think that is cynical.
So I will not call her that.
She is lovely.
Full stop.
And she so everybody out there
pray for her to get into either
UVA or Upenn.
Those are her what she calls
stretches.
But I told her that if she can
write an amazing narrative about
being, you know, pura Vida and
like, you know, having a Costa
Rican dad and like all that
other stuff like she.
She'll get her position at one
of those schools.
So, and then I was thinking
about my conversations with my
buddy Mark Harrison over the
last 30 years, 33 years, 40
years.
And I was thinking about how I
was seeing, about how I learned
as a dive master, a Patty dive
master.
And a dive photographer with my
dad, Bob Abraham.
Robert John Abraham.
I realized as a free diver and a
scuba diver and a diver in
Hawaii.
Nay, and especially as a
photographer, I realized that
what you need to do when you go
underwater is you need to slow
your breath.
You need to calm down and you
need to stop chasing everything.
You need to stop chasing
everything.
You need to actively sit back,
stop, look and listen.
And I dare say that my last 10
years in Arlington.
Much more so than Portland or
Berlin or Norwich or Hawaii or
DC, even.
Because I've been sick and
tired.
And because I died at at 47.
I died for three minutes.
And because this is a boring
neighborhood and a shitty
community and none of my friends
are impressed.
And it's.
Garbagey and crappy and I live
like a pauper.
I've had the freedom to use my
scuba diving strategy on the
daily.
I leave my apartment on a daily
scuba dive of my neighborhood.
Because I'm on foot, I don't
move very fast.
Because I am 53 and grizzled, I
don't attract that much
attention.
Because I'm slow and casual, I
and because I spent a lot of
time sitting around while
working in cafes and parks,
walking down the street at
libraries and so forth, I treat
each place like Starbucks on
Penrose or Ididos or.
Main Library Arlington or
Shirlington library or my local
Columbia Pike Arlington Library.
I treat every place as if it's a
a different dive spots in a
different coral reef.
And then I just go there and I
spend time.
And because I'm slow and because
I'm observant, I notice all the.
More eels hiding in the holes.
And I notice all the sleepa
lobster and I notice all the
Dakine octopus.
You know, I see the clown fish
in the Humu Humu Nuku Nuku Abu
Ah.
And I see the Pacific green sea
turtle and I see the.
Eagle Ray and I see the manta
ray and I see the white tip and
the black tip.
Sharks and I see the
hammerheads, and in the distance
I see the dolphins and I see the
humpbacks and I see the pilot
whales.
And I have plenty of time
because my entire life is about
making sure that my tank of
compressed air.
Lasts all day long, and because
I only hang out at around 30
feet or one atmosphere, my my
compressed air lasts.
Lasts forever.
And so instead of chasing around
pretty baristas being like, hey,
hey, how's it going hey, I just
sit back and if.
And I live my life and I'm not
antisocial, but I'm not keen.
I mean, one should never, when
one is out of high school, ever
pursue friendship with a 10 year
old girl, with an 18 year old
girl, with a 17 year old girl,
with anybody.
Like that's not your space.
So you just need to, you just
need everybody to know.
That you are not a spear hunter.
That you're just a recreational
diver, and that all you want to
do is take pictures and you're
not pokey or or touchy or
steely.
You're not there to, like,
bother, the more a eel or chase
the frickin green sea turtle or
be an annoyance.
If anything, you might bring
down some, some, you know,
chopped up fish or, you know,
you might even get to the point
where the eel allows you to
stroke it.
Or, you know, even though in
Hawaii it's illegal to touch
green sea turtles, I've had
green sea turtles approach me
and I've had dolphins approach
me and I've had pilot whales
approach me.
And I've had humpback whales
approach me and I've had, you
know, I've had octopuses trust
me enough to go ahead and crawl
up on me and leave all their
sucker marks.
And that's how I want to engage
the world.
Wherever I'm at, I want to be a
safe enough recreational diver,
scuba diver, so that you know.
10 year old little girls at park
run races can befriend me as a
chum and teach me how to take
numbers or a 17 year old barista
with aspirations of UVA or pen
that they want to give me a hug
as opposed to.
Creepy freak who's like, give me
hug, give me hug, give me
attention, give me hug, pretty
girl, blah.
I want to be the kind of guy
that a beautiful barista,
pregnant woman who's seen me for
the last 10 years in the
neighborhood.
I want her to feel like she
comes up to me at Starbucks and
gives me a Tumblr and a little
card thanking me for being a
good.
A good customer instead of me
holding court.
I never want to hold court.
I want to be accepted into your
court.
I never want to be the main
character.
I want to be in the front row.
I never want to be the active
player.
Even when I think about video
games, I'm the guy who watches
other people play video games.
On YouTube or or or Twitch or
Switch or bitch or Lich or
whatever.
Like I'm not the guy who likes
to play whatever Zelda.
I like seeing other people do
that kind of stuff.
I treat it like a movie, and if
anything, I want to be the NPC
in your life I want to be.
Thinking about role-playing
games, like like online
role-playing games like Dungeon
Dragons and so forth, I want to
be that townsman who comes up to
you and like and you click on
them and you you click talk and
they're like, hello fellow
traveler, it is so great to see
you.
We've been attacked by an
endless amount of pirates and
we're hoping that you.
Hero will be able to protect us.
I hear that there's a amazing
plus five shield and plus 10
sword, and we think that if you
get that back you can protect
our town.
Good luck.
Let me know if there's anything
you need.
Pura, Vida and Aloha.
That's who I want to be.
I have no desire to hold court.
I have no desire to be the
epicenter of anything.
And it's working so far by
treating my little community, my
15 minute city, as if I were a
good-natured recreational diver
who just wants to have a lovely,
memorable experience with his
eyeballs and maybe his camera,
but not with his spear or his
gun.
Or his bag of stealing or his
whatever.
Then this is my advice to you.
I feel like, I feel like this is
always rewarded.
Like this morning there's this
like really super handsome fit
guy who sits outside and works
and he up till now hasn't really
lifted his eyes or like engaged
with me or whatever.
And.
Yesterday I think I said
something and he was just like
whatever.
And I was sitting in the in the
cafe at the single comfy chair
and and he walked by to go to
the bathroom and he said hello
to me, right.
So I had spent enough time just
being familiar and friendly and
but not needy not thirsty as the
kids say.
That you know he eventually just
said hello, right.
And I'm willing to wait forever.
Like I'm there's another saying
that I've been attached to,
which is live life, not attached
to outcome.
Like do your part but don't get
like don't don't get attached to
your outcome.
So so the same thing there's
this this quirky dude.
Who has like so many shopping
bags, like the like the paper
kind of bags that you get at
Whole Foods and he slips around
with them and he carries a
obviously defensive stick, a
metal stick and he sits there
with his glasses on and his hat
on and gives out like semi
homeless.
Crazy vibes, slight African
American man.
And here comes a helicopter.
That helicopter was low enough
that it threw a shadow in the
park that I'm at.
I'm at Penrose, sorry.
I'm at Walter Reed Community
Park and I'm watching some
people play pickleball.
I took you on a walk from my
dittos to here, so Oh yeah.
So every time I go to the
bathroom, if he catches my eye,
nod at him.
That went on.
Catch his eye, nodded him.
Catch his eye.
Happened for weeks.
Because I can tell that the guy
was fronting the guy was like
using I'm fucking crazy as his
defensive wall.
His like, I deserve to be here.
His, his, his, like space
control, right?
He kind of sets up his bags and
stuff and kind of takes up
space.
One day I was heading to the
bathroom and he pops up and we
start talking and he reminds me
of he's so smart and quick and
witty and funny and intelligent
and charming and he told me his
name is Bridgewater.
So I remember his name is
Bridgewater.
So every time we see each other,
we chat, we share dive reports,
dive logs.
And everybody at Starbucks knows
how charming and interesting and
so forth.
But it took me a long time for
me to engage what I saw as a
Maury Eel man.
He was a big toothy Maury eel.
And just by just by visiting his
choral every day, eventually he
knew that knew that I was not a
threat.
I was not competition.
I was not judgy.
But for for us, the fact that he
was carrying a baton was also
red flag for me, right?
Like anybody with a baton or
concealed carry or even a flick
pocket knife, utility knife like
is a potential threat.
And I I'm not naive.
If I notice a threat, I take
note of it in my head and I
prepare accordingly.
So.
He was always had the asterisk
has a metal baton, but doesn't
hide it like he has it just
there and he walks with it.
Anywhere he goes, he he
brandishes his metal baton.
So that makes me wary of him.
That makes me see that he is to
quote my episode 33, he is a
very he's a, he's a rattlesnake.
Very comfortably rattling,
rattling, rattling, rattling.
And I needed to be the best
snake charmer I could be, right?
I needed the snake to put away
its rattle and put away its
fangs.
And now Bridgewater and I are
chums.
And if I give you any advice, my
advice is to not just to be your
best self publicly.
And openly catch everybody's
eyes, smile gently, nod gently,
and then be consistent.
Be a little playful, Take a
little bit of a risk.
Go out of your way to befriend.
But then if you take a risk and
befriend or have story time or
assert yourself.
On conversation.
Then back off.
Back the F off.
Do not treat it like you've
taken a hill and you own that
hill.
If you take the hill, give the
hill back.
You take the hill.
Give the hell back.
Eventually, hopefully, if you're
doing it right, the hill will
invite you to tea.
The hill will invite you to
dinner.
The hill will become your
friend.
I do not deserve to have a 10
year old little girlfriend.
I might not have a little 11
year old friend, but if, if the
mom, if the little girl and so
forth ever want to invite me to
tea, I will surely gladly bring
flowers.
And what is it?
Scones.
What do people bring to tea?
Scones, Tea.
Sandwiches.
The barista today, 1718 year old
girl.
I will always give up two hills.
Make sure she feels totally
comfortable inviting me to tea.
I will not overstay my tea time.
I will not assume that if I give
tea sandwiches that I am owed
anything back.
The entire thing is paid in full
with the time.
Attention in conversation
forever and ever, I'm in.
I'm not playing a game of trying
to win hills.
I'm not trying to win a war.
There's no battle going on.
I will always gladly seed back
any, any land that I get.
If I feel like the people there
have no interest in continuing
the friendship, I will always
ask for permission.
I will always ask for consent.
I will always make it sound not
serious, like it's play, so that
nobody feels like they have to
say something so as to save
face.
And then I will come back
tomorrow.
And never, never assume that we
are in the same relationship
that we were last time.
There's nothing to lose, man.
What do they say?
The more you give it away, the
more it comes back.
The more you let it go, the more
it returns.
It seems to work.
And then never get attached to
outcomes.
Never expect.
Never, never.
Never require anybody to give
you their agency.
Never expect anybody to give you
their autonomy.
Never.
Assume that it's a game of
dominance or 0 sum game.
There's enough love to go around
and you don't want love that's
not opted in.
You don't want love where every
day when you meet someone again,
they don't have an opportunity
to always choose you.
As an only child of narcissists,
I know all the tools.
To manipulate people into loving
me.
But that's not real love, man.
At all.
That sucks.
And the moment the person finds
an exit, they're the F out of
there.
Anyway, I hope this was useful
and I love you and I don't
expect you to come back, but I
would love if you will.
And I hope you have a merry
scuba dive in your local
neighborhood forever and ever.
I'm in.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.
Now.